a like a social media company or a
government that has come up with like a
hashtag campaign for men I'm being real
has any is there I'm not aware of any
where's body positivity for men but
who's the little who's the largest
voting block gay pride I mean like like
that sort of thing so that's not meant
that's not men Centric that's awesome
okay I can't actually remember the name
but there was something to do with um
like men and like
um you know suicide type of thing that
there's no homicide awareness or
something a higher percentage of mine
that commits suicide and stuff I think I
think there was but yeah there's other
men that want more rights for their
children you know that yeah dress up in
um fancy dress and they climb buildings
and they try to make a point about men
having more rights for children maybe
not so much the the last few years but
in the last 10 years I could say so we
have to sit around here and dig and dig
and be like hey do you remember that one
like kind of movement there was maybe
led by men but